[Musique]
maintenant débat sur france 24 alors que
la guerre en ukraine entre dans son
septième mois les craintes d'une
catastrophe nucléaire dans la centrale
de zappos ridja ne faiblissent pas ce
week-end la compagnie nationale
ukrainienne energoatom a mis en garde
contre la fuite d'hydrogène et de
pulvérisation de substances radioactives
le risque d'incendié est élevé les
autorités de la région ont même commencé
à distribuer des comprimés d'iodé aux
habitants ce matin le directeur de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique a annoncé l'envoi d'une
délégation
raphaël grossi conduit lui-même cette
mission d'au moins une dizaine de
personnes elle arrivera sur place plus
tard cette semaine at il mentionné vous
voyez sur twitter la communauté
internationale souhaite mettre en place
une zone démilitarisée autour de la
centrale afin de la sécuriser alors
quelles sont ces risques d'un accident
nucléaire azapo ridja comment la mission
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique peut-elle travailler en plein
conflit cette menace nucléaire et elle
d'autant plus forte que la guerre en
ukraine risque d'être longue on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés karine herviou bonsoir à vous
sous directrice générale adjointe de
l'institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire
bienvenue dans le débat à côté de vous
claude blanchemaison bonsoir je vois
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
hauteur de vivre avec poutine le montre
c'était il ya trois ans c'était avant la
guerre n'est ce pas mais ça reste très
instructif nous avons avec nous
également par skype de kiev tetyana
hoggar kova à bonsoir journaliste
responsable du département international
à l'ukraine crisis médias à saintes
bienvenue à vous dans le débat va nous
rejoindre dans quelques minutes il est
un peu en retard dominique train quand
l'ancien chef de la mission militaire
française auprès des nations unies a
zappé orridge a bien sûr vous pouvez
participer au débat j'allais l'oublier
en posant vos questions quand vous
voulez à partir de maintenant sur le
conte h 24 pardon h débat f24 on attend
bien sûr vos questions et vos réactions
tout au long de l'émission zaporizhya
est la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'europe elle se situe
dans le sud de l'ukraine sur le
territoire de la ville denner dausgaard
énerve d'audard pardon déjà je vais y
arriver henner audard cette centrale est
sous contrôle russe depuis le mois de
mars mais les opérateurs sont
ukrainiennes c'est une centrale qui est
dotée de six réacteurs de 1000 mégawatts
elle dispose d'une capacité de près de
6000 mégawatts c'est à dire assez
d'énergie pour augmenter de près pour
alimenter près de 4 millions de foyers
en électricité la communauté
internationale voudrait une zone
démilitarisée autour de cette centrale
afin de la sécuriser une mission
arrivera je vous le disais sur place
plus tard cette semaine ont fait le
point en images avec nicolas chamontin
sur cette photo quatorze membres de
l'aiea sur le point de se diriger vers
la centrale nucléaire de zaporijia à la
tête de cette délégation raphaël grossi
le directeur général de l'agencé
onusienne conscient de l'enjeu que revêt
cette visite le jour est venu la mission
de la lui avait rapporté dja est
désormais en route nous devons protéger
la sécurité de l'ukraine et de la plus
grande centrale d'europe les
observateurs de l'aiea devrait rallier
le site plus tard dans la semaine jeudi
dernier au micro de france 24 raphaël
grossi évoqué les objectifs de cette
mission en zone de guerre avec mes
experts techniques donc on fera un état
des lieux si vous voulez donc on faire à
des réparations on va rétablir des
systèmes de transmission d'informations
que qui ont été endommagées et après
probablement on va assurer une présence
continue des lagence la centrale de
zaporizhya est occupée par les forces
russes depuis les premiers jours de la
guerre le site est toujours exploité par
des techniciens ukrainien et fournit de
l'électricité à tout le pays mais depuis
plusieurs semaines des frappes ont
atteint les environs de la centrale
alors que la russie accuse l'ukraine
d'attaquer le site kiev affirme que
l'armée russe l'utilisent pour stocker
des armes et lancer des attaques en
déplacement en suède
le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères a mis en garde contre les
dangers encourus par les experts de
l'argentine
sans exagération cette mission sera la
plus difficile de l'histoire de la ja
étant donné les activités de combat
active menée par la fédération de russie
sur le terrain nous attendons de la
mission une déclaration claire des faits
de violation de tous les protocoles de
sécurité nucléaire
ces derniers jours l'agente ukrainienne
energoatom alerte sur des risques de
fuites radioactives
la situation fait planer la menace d'un
incident nucléaire majeur
karine herviou vécu est l'expert fin de
ce plateau expert en nucléaire dans quel
état d'abord et cette centrale est ce qu
on a des informations alors à priori à
deux réacteurs qui sont toujours en
fonctionnement sur cette centrale qui
sont connectés au réseau
une craignent uns et les autres rector
sont pour l'instant à l'arrêt
vraisemblable avec du combustible chargé
ils peuvent redémarrer si besoin
et quels sont les risques justement
d'une catastrophe éventuel nucléaire est
ce qu on pourrait parler d'un nouveau
tchernobyl est ce que ça serait plus
proche de fukushima si ça arrivait ou du
three mile island américain alors le
risque majeur il concerne effectivement
les réacteurs et les piscines
d'entreposage du combustible usé donc
les recteurs le coeur du réacteur il est
situé dans ces bâtiments cylindrique en
béton ainsi que les piscines le
principal risque pour nous il est sur la
perte des alimentations électriques
depuis le mois de mars on a vu des
lignes de haute tension qui permettent
d'alimenter la centrale qui ont été
perdus la semaine dernière l'ensemble
des lignes principales d'alimentation
centrale ont été perdus et la centrale a
été déconnecté du réseau heureusement
unis n'a été rétablie donc tous à l'en
croire cela comporte un risque alors le
risque c'est que
le recteur ne soient plus refroidis donc
c'est cette alimentation électrique elle
est nécessaire pour alimenter les
systèmes de secours qui en cas d'arrêt
du réacteur permettent de refroidir le
combustible
alors si cette alimentation électrique
externe est perdu il y assure le site un
certain nombre de sources internes des
groupes électrogènes de type diesel il y
en a à peu près une vingtaine sur la
centrale deux abris dia qui vont prendre
le relais mais ces groupes électrogènes
de secours ils ont besoin de carburant
aujourd'hui sur la centrale il y a des
réserves qui permettent de tenir sept à
dix jours au delà il faut soit
ravitailler la centrale en carburant
soit rétablie rue ni d'alimentation
électrique sinon le risque c'est d'aller
à l'accident grave comme on l'a connu à
fukushima donc fusion du coeur et des
rejets plus significatifs dans
l'environnement le risque majeur il est
là tetiana au regard kova vous qui êtes
à kiev selon l'opérateur ukrainien il ya
eu dix habitants qui ont été blessées à
la suite de bombardements sur place il y
aurait quatre employés d'ailleurs de la
centrale toujours selon energoatom est
ce que les ukrainiens redoute
effectivement un incident voir un
accident nucléaire
oui bonsoir oui en fait l'inquiétude
était ce jour là puisque il faut dire
que les ukrainiens ont toujours cette
mémoire traumatique et traumatisante de
tchernobyl donc quand on nous dit
nucléaire ici à ne créer bien sûr que ça
fait peur parce que on observe mais ceci
depuis plus de 30 ans des maladies qui
sont dieu justement au nucléaire
après ce qui se passe sur place c'est
vrai c'est aussi inquiétant surtout la
semaine dernière can pires moments qui a
duré si je me trompe pas quelques heures
seulement le moment de la coupure de
ravitaillement reading dérobé cayman et
on craignait vraiment qu'on pouvait
apprendre le scénario de voilà de que
les stocks ne pouvait pas se refroidir
ça faisait très très peur en fait mais
après très vite la limiter resterait
donc avec deux recteurs qui marche vous
dit on est un peu plus calme mais bien
sûr que ça sacré sacré 7 ce plan
d'inquiétude et bien sûr on comprend que
la centrale et d'éléments de reus et
ceci depuis le mois de mars et qu'il
utilise justement dans les buts de
chantage on voit tous les jours presque
tous les jours les tirs vers nikopol
nikopol
situé en face de nrk odeurs donc des
tirs des provocations pour faire germer
craignant de répondre ce qui les fait
pas entrer mais c'est à dire que quand
il ya un objet comme centrales
nucléaires et militarisé c'est à dire
qu'il ya une présence militaire il ya
toujours des risques puisqu'on sait pas
où sont stockés les chars et les blindés
les systèmes d'artillerie qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire avec qu'elle chantait
l'autre chantage il va faire bien sûr on
comprend que même le chantage et les
suicidaires parce que on comprend aussi
on essaie de rationaliser on comprend
que les dégâts seront néfastes pas
seulement pour l'ukraine comme le
nucléaire n'a pas de frontières le nuage
peut aller tout aussi bien en russie
qu'en europe ça dépend du vent et c'est
très difficile de prévoir donc donc mais
ça constitue l' angoisse vraiment réel
je dirais des millions d'ukrainiens vous
parlez donc voit sa cote branche maison
est effectivement il ya un chantage
exercé par les russes autour de cette
centrale c'est la première fois qu'une
centrale nucléaire se trouve dans une
zone de guerre ça ne s'est jamais
produit et sa part est monstrueux qu'une
centrale nucléaire puisse être dans une
zone de guerre ce qui fait que les deux
belligérants s'accusent mutuellement de
risquer de faire sauter à réacteurs ou
de provoquer des fuites puissent qui
s'accusent mutuellement de bombarder la
zone contiguë pas les réacteurs
eux-mêmes mais la zone continue qui côté
geek et sur le domaine et puis par
ailleurs il n'ya jamais eu non plus une
centrale nucléaire qui fasse partie
d'une zone d'occupation militaire or
c'est le cas les militaires russes
occupent la centrale la centrale
nucléaire est probablement avec des vins
tensions politico économiques qui ne
sont pas acceptables par les ukrainiens
à savoir de d'obtenir dans les jours qui
viennent après naturellement la mission
de la ja que ces centrales puissent
alimenter par exemple la crimée par
exemple l'arrière-pays de la crimée que
l'armée russe occupe voire même une
partie du territoire russe doukkali
stratégique finalement pour les russes
c'est un enjeu économique en effet et
les russes le considère comme un comme
un enjeu stratégique 2013 quand vous
avez rejoint sur ce plateau ancien chef
de la mission militaire française auprès
des nations unies bonsoir sur un bon
soir à vous donc hier faut effectivement
qu'une centrale se retrouve au coeur
d'un conflit est ce que vous pensez que
l peu de fac elle est une sorte de
bouclier militaire pour les russes
qu'ils stockent effectivement à certains
noms leurs d'armement lourd comme le
disent les ukrainiens alors d'abord elle
est essentiel aussi bien aux russes
cause ukrainien elle est essentielle aux
russes qui l'ont saisi dès les premiers
jours de l'offensive pour alimenter
toutes les parties occupé aujourd'hui
par la russie donc il dévie
effectivement la provenance fall
électricité vers bien gérée occupait
alors la crimée cesser leurs objectifs
bien sûr de même que le canal qui a été
conquis pour alimenter la crimée est
important à partir du dieppe donc c'est
pour faire vivre la zone occupée par la
russie
le secrétaire général des nations unies
ne s'y est pas trompé lorsqu'il était à
lui il parlait du courant en disant
l'électricité et ukrainienne est à dire
que la centrale est occupée par là aussi
mais l'électricité doit rester
ukrainienne et là c'est essentiel pour
l'ukraine parce que compte tenu de la
capacité de production de cette centrale
évidemment que l'ukraine en a besoin
donc partant de ce constat la
l'occupation comme le disait monsieur
l'ambassadeur l'occupation c'est la
première fois que ça arrive que c'est au
milieu d'une zone de conflit et que en
plus c'est occuper vraiment inédit ça
n'est jamais arrivé n'est jamais arrivé
alors les matériels qui sont dans le
porte-parole de il n'ya pas longtemps
mais porte parole russe disait il n'ya
pas d'armements lourds à l'intérieur de
la centrale ça veut pas dire que c'est
pas à côté on sait qu'il ya des
matériels militaires à l'intérieur on a
vu des images c'était des camions qui
étaient à l'intérieur mais en tout état
de cause le sujet d'une centrale au
milieu d'une zone de guerre c'est un
nouveau sujet il faut neutraliser
c'est une évidence mais le diable est
dans les détails l'inspection de l'eeie
a qui va arriver là bas va peut-être
permettre d'avoir un constat objectif
sur ce qui se passe mais sur la durée ne
va pas régler le problème parce que les
russes ne vont pas autant de laisser
deux centrales et ukrainien pour
l'instant ce sont totalement dans la
capacité de la conquérir en tout cas la
communauté internationale voudrait créer
une sorte de zone démilitarisée autour
de cette centrale afin de la sécuriser
mission donc on le disait arrivera sur
place plus tard cette semaine on fait le
point justement sur une écoute emmanuel
macron plutôt
la sûreté et la sécurité nucléaires ne
saurait être fragilisé par cette guerre
est donc cette mission est importante
elle doit préserver cette centrale et la
sécurité de la sûreté de toute la région
la deuxième c'est que la souveraineté
ukrainienne sur cette centrale ne doit
pas être contestées le nucléaire ne doit
pas être un objet de la guerre et il est
important de défendre là aussi la
souveraineté ukrainienne sûre cette
centrale le président français qui
soutient bien sûr cette mission caréné
review que peuvent véritablement faire
la mission de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique
rafa est grossi nous disait la semaine
dernière que l aller inspecter sur place
voir justement réparé et même des dégâts
ce qu'elle peut réparer les dégâts et de
quels dégâts parle-t-on exactement je
sais pas si elle va réparer les dégâts
en tout cas ça va permettre de faire un
état des lieux de la situation sans
doute de prendre contact avec
l'exploitant ukrainien 1 depuis
l'invasion russe en fait l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui doit exercer un
contrôle de la sûreté ne peut plus
intervenir sur le site donc ça permettra
de faire vraiment un état des lieux de
savoir quelles sont les conditions
d'exploitation de cette centrale est ce
que les règles de sûreté qui s'applique
à cette centrale peuvent être sont bien
appliquées par exemple est-ce que les la
maintenance des équipements importants
pour la sûreté est fait est-ce qu'ils
ont les compétences le personnel sur
place quel est l'état des du personnel
ukrainien on peut imaginer un la version
6 de pression parce que disait ukrainien
que finalement ce personnel craignent la
suppression des russes est-ce qu'ils
vont véritablement voir la vérité est ce
que ça sera factuel finalement cette
taxe en sélection je le pense c'est ce
que va essayer de comprendre les yeux as
que les processus de décision sont ce
qu'ils doivent être dans une centrale
nucléaire ou est-ce que c'est sous
pression russe c'est en tout cas ce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire et aussi
d'établir des contacts pour l'avenir
comme l'a rappelé raphaël grossi tetyana
hoggar koval opérateurs craignent à lui
assure que les forces russes mettent
justement la pression sur le personnel
de la centrale pour les empêcher de
révéler les preuves
justement du l'épreuve par exemple
d'armements lourds ou les preuves de
crimes russe c'est ce que disent en tout
cas les ukrainiens
oui tout à fait il ya des publications
qui allaient dans ce sens c'est aussi
une région pas seulement crier mais
aussi si je ne trompe pas il y avait des
médias britanniques qui ont interviewé
sort a minima d'aider le personnel
quelqu'un de personnel de la station
nucléaire donc ils ont parlé des
tortures véritablement des tortures et
de la mise en scène qui était en train
de se préparer à la centrale c'est à
dire qu'il attend déjà la mission de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique avec les attentes ils vont
mettre à chaque pièce où l'inspection va
passer et vont mettre en russie à chaque
pièce et puis après les ukrainiens
effrayer depuis plusieurs mois de
captivité il faut rappeler que le
personnel de ces stations excellait à
11000 personnes vous imaginez ces normes
en fait ils sont tous n'ont pas droit de
sortir n'ont pas droit d'aller à la
maison n'ont pas n'ont pas droit de
noces échanges et serra n'ont pas parlé
droit de parler après ils sont torturés
en tout cas c'était le mot employé par
le média britannique telegraph il ya
quelques jours donc on peut imaginer que
les russes vont font dire à les
ukrainiens le personnel que tout va bien
qu on est très heureux que les russes
ont pris vos lacets station qu'on est
con et ainsi tueur était que tout se
passe correctement mais il faut savoir
que les paroles qui seront dites ils
sont dites par des gens qui sont sous
pression mais vraiment énorme ici et
ceux ci plaisir depuis plusieurs mois
faisant vous êtes d'accord en fait ça
sera quand même très compliqué pour 7
ils sont déjà d'arriver parce qu'il faut
qu'ils arrivent sur place a priori parce
que comme le disait le général tout à
l'heure je pense que les russes comme
les ukrainiens ont intérêt à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas d'incident de type nucléaire
pour que c'est la raison pour laquelle
dons qu'ils acceptent aujourd'hui
finalement scellé mais alors conditions
et les conditions sont pas les mêmes de
chaque côté et effectivement le premier
défi auquel va se heurter la mission les
l aiea ça va être comment faire comment
obtenir du commandant des 500 militaires
russes qui sont dans la centrale qui de
laisser la mission de l'aïe a interviewé
les
les membres de l'équipe ukrainienne qui
fait tourner la centrale les interviewer
un par un parce qu'après tout parmi eux
il ya peut-être des espions aussi de les
interviewer un parent de façon anonyme
pour être sûr qu'ils vont dire la vérité
alors bien sûr les russes vont déployer
tout un tas de dispositifs y compris je
vous ives d'ecoute pour savoir ce que
les employés iraniens
s'excuse auprès n'y ait pas trois on
raconte à la halle à la mission en effet
à la mission du delà de la u a donc
c'est une tâche très difficile en plus
combien de temps va durer cette mission
la presse russe parle de trois ou quatre
jours c'est évidemment pas suffisant
pour se rendre compte de ce qui se passe
exactement d'établir des rapports de
confiance avec les gens qui travaillent
et d'ailleurs je grossis a bien dit que
l'un de ses objectifs était de
pérenniser la mission et c'est bien ce
que les russes ne veulent pas faire
parce qu'ils vont retirer tout le
matériel militaire qui traînent aux
alentours avant il va attendant les
quelques jours a bien sûr et leur met
ensuite en place donc ils ne veulent pas
d'une mission permanente de 1000 trains
quand pourquoi il accepte finalement les
russes tout de même cette mission parce
qu'il est évidemment opposé les
ukrainiens aussi parce qu'il ne voulait
pas qu'on mette en place une sorte de
situation de fait un de contrôle des
rues ce nom alors je pense que les
russes le président poutine lors de sa
conversation avec le président macron a
joué une communication très fine c'est à
dire que souvenez vous depuis des jours
on parlait des bombardements et depuis
début jour les ukrainiens visés sont les
russes qui bombarde et russes dix essais
les ukrainiens qui bombarde et là le
président poutine arrivé dit mais moi je
suis pour une inspection pour aller
vérifier les choses parce qu'on sait
bien que les bombardements les russes ne
se tirait pas dessus mais en revanche la
sûreté nucléaire et difficulté la
centrale sont réels donc il veut montrer
qu'il est le bon élève qui a pas de
problème convient mais on vient le
diable est l'un des détails à des
condition qu'il accepte donc si vous
voulez si au bout de 3 jours 10 bon ça
va vous avez tous vu vous maintenant
vous partez ben les inspecteurs vont
être un peu dans la difficulté pour
rendre ils vont pouvoir dire bah écoutez
il n'y a pas de radiations n'y a pas de
machin mais on n'a pas pu interroger
tout le monde mais et cetera donc je
pense que les russes ont vraiment
intérêt sachant qu'ils ne quitteront pas
cette centrale elle est trop importante
pour eux ont intérêt à montrer qu'ils
sont des bons élèves qu'ils ne veulent
pas d'incident nucléaire mais ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y en aura pas donc on
se parle pas de démilitarisation de la
zone à ce nom mais la démilitarisation
de la zone ça me paraît totalement
illusoire ça veut dire que les russes
déciderait de partir ça voudrait dire
quoi ouvrir la porte aux ukrainiens
jamais de la vie
donc je ne vois pas les russes
démilitarisé par ailleurs il ya eu des
bruits qui couraient sur une mission de
l'onu pour neutraliser avec des casques
bleus et où je n'y crois pas une seconde
ça ça passe par le conseil de sécurité
et je peux vous dire que le reste vont
tout de suite mettre un veto donc il n'y
aura pas de mission de casques bleus de
l'onu sur la centrale car nerfs view est
ce que justement le fait que cette
guerre manifestement soit longue en tout
cas on parle encore d'un an est-ce que
ça veut dire que ce risque nucléaire
sera de plus enfin qui s'est tant fait
qu'il sera d'autant plus élevé oui on
voit que la situation se dégrade
insidieusement il ya la problématique de
l'entretien de ces réacteurs des pièces
de rechange est ce que les prestataires
qui interviennent pour entretenir cette
centrale sont toujours là ce qu'ils
peuvent accéder sur le site donc sur le
long terme il y à des questions qui se
posent il faudra aussi réalimenté la
centrale en combustible neuf donc ça
veut dire des transports de combustibles
pour amener du combustible neuf sur la
centrale aujourd'hui c'est difficilement
envisageable compte tenu de la situation
militaire donc oui une situation qui se
dégrade petit à petit et quand même pour
le personnel encore une fois une
situation au long cours qui perdure et
qui n'est évidemment pas souhaitable
d'un point de vue sûreté le personnel
doit pouvoir agir en toute tranquillité
et garder une vigilance sur l'état de
l'installation parce qu'il faut rappeler
donc un qu'il ya un contrôle russe mais
qu'effectivement donc le personnel sur
place et toujours est une craignent un
tetyana hoggar kova cette guerre on
apprend aujourd'hui en fait qu'il ya eu
contre offensive ukrainienne à carson
dans le sud de l'ukraine d'abord
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
cette contre offensive est ce que vous
pensez que cette guerre va être longue
mais en fait on a reçu l'information
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient des contrats
talent je parle est vrai pas d'une
contre offensive massive à ce moment là
mais qui était vraiment que l'armée
ukrainienne enfants commence à libérer
petit à petit les des villages et des
localités au sud à côté de personnes il
faut dire que cette contre offensive
était annoncé et ceci depuis plusieurs
semaines ça veut dire tout simplement
que l'ukraine va pas s'arrêter avant le
libérer complètement pas uniquement le
sud de l'ukraine dans nos personnes vers
gasc mario pole mais aussi les crimes et
et après bien sûr le donbass quand on
dit que c'est bien pour la première fois
qu'un objet nucléaire se retrouve au
centre de conflits tu tiens à rappeler
aussi que la station de tchernobyl était
en captivité était capturé par des
russes au mois de février et donc rien
n'a empêché à l'armée ukrainienne de les
libérer de les faire partir enfin de
faire partir des troupes russes on peut
utiliser les mêmes méthodes pour faire
un parti partir les troupes russes de la
centrale de de denner godard en fait
puisqu'il suffit de de dole et de les
assurer de l'hérault pouces et bien sûr
sans toucher à la à la centrale puisque
les conséquences sont néfastes mais on
croit toujours que l'état major du
craignant à bien un plan dans la tête
comment agir et comment les faire
proposer ce qui est le seul scénario
acceptable pour les craintes que
danseuse est d'accord en fait il y aura
toujours il va continuer à avoir un
conflit autour donc de cette centrale
qui reste un enjeu majeur et les
ukrainiens comme vient de le dire
tetyana au regard kova tiennent ils vont
essayer de récupérer comme ils ont fait
avec tchernobyl parce que tchernobyl ça
remonte à un certain nombre de mois
effectivement mais la sphère de la de
personnes que vous évoquez la
contre-offensive ukrainienne sur cassure
carson je crois est distincte de la
sphère de la centrale dont nous parlions
parce que personne c'est un autre enjeu
clé pour les deux belligérants est un
enjeu clé évidemment pour
les ukrainiens parce que c'est la ville
qui a été occupée aceto parlait parlait
russe et qui est la plus à la plus à
l'ouest la plus au sud ouest finalement
sur le sur le débouché du dniepr mais
pour les russes c'est aussi essentiel
puisque ils l'ont conquise et ils ont
ils sont employés à la russie fier
depuis qu'ils sont en place ils compris
en changeant les manuels scolaires les
instituteurs etc et en faisant une
propagande insensé par conséquent la
dessus je ne suis pas je dois pas très
bien les russes céder facilement à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne alors il se
peut en effet que les ukrainiens
parviennent à avancer tant mieux mais je
ne suis pas sûr que les russes se
lassent très facilement exclu cette
personne d'autant plus que politiquement
le kremlin avait indiqué qu'il avait
l'intention le mois prochain de faire un
référendum pour créer un nouvel état
fantoche comme il y en a deux autres
dans le donbass sous obédience russe
bien entendu et donc renoncer à ce
projet politique pour la russie
évidemment ce à un coût très élevé et
moi je pense que si les ukrainiens
arrive à refouler le rouleau compresseur
russe tant mieux bien entendu mais je
pense que si les russes sont acculés à
un moment donné à une sorte de défaite
ou de capitulation qui est quand même
l'objectif que poursuit monsieur henin
ce qui est bien à ce moment là ils
risquent d'utiliser des armes d'un ou
d'une autre nature que celle qu'ils ont
utilisés jusqu'à présent c'était nickel
ben c'est à dire c'est à dire les armes
nucléaires tactiques quand même parler
d'un autre risque nucléaire c'est un
autre risque nucléaire personne ne sait
peut-être le général a une idée sur
notre doctrine en matière d'armes
nucléaires tactiques mais personne ne
sait quelle serait la réaction des pays
occidentaux à usage d'un obus tactique
quelque part le long du nieppe parce que
nous n'en avons pas il nous n'avons pas
de cris dans la matière nous nous
raisonnons en armes nucléaires
stratégiques moscou devait y avoir on
l'apprend en faire échouer des
offensives ukrainienne dans la région de
kherson et de nicolas yves donc ça je
voudrais ce que ce que vous dites 2005
en jeu juste deux points d'abord pour
terminer sur la centrale de hamaoka
il n'y a qu'à pardonnez moi mais c'est
pas si simple que ça je rappelle que la
la centrale de tchernobyl avait été
abandonné par les russes et a été
reprise par les ukrainiens n'y a pas eu
de combat pour leur prendre alors que
dans le cas de produits déjà c'est un
autre sujet donc je crois que c'est pas
aussi simple que ça bon le 2 le deuxième
point sur l'offensive de kherson je
pense que c'est la bonne stratégie
ukrainienne elle choisit son terrain
elle concentre ses efforts et elle a
travaillé depuis plusieurs semaines
puisque c'était annoncé depuis plusieurs
semaines pour shape de bateaux furent
comme disent les américains je rappelle
que ce sont les américains qui ont formé
les ukrainiens c'est à dire travailler
dans la profondeur casser les ponts sur
le nieppe et enfermer les troupes à
l'ouest du nieppe jeudi choisir le
terrain pourquoi parce que c'est la
seule poche qui est à l'ouest du nieppe
et donc c'est essentiel elle a été
conquise très rapidement mais imaginez
vous que les forces russes qui sont dans
cette zone là avec personne qui a fait
beaucoup preuve de résistance les
ukrainiens ont fait beaucoup d'actes de
résistance que cette poche les troupes
russes qui sont là sont enfermés dans
cette poche les pc des troupes qui était
à l'ouest l'uniap sont déjà passés à
l'ess le lièvre donc ça veut dire pour
les ut pour les russes c'est une
catastrophe ça veut dire que non
seulement ils perdent l'ouest du nieppe
mais ils ont peut-être des troupes qui
seront faites prisonnières et ça
évidemment pour le président poutine
c'est une catastrophe et donc on arrive
aux extrêmes qui était présentée par
monsieur l'ambassadeur
non moi je ne prends pas d'abord un obus
ça sert à quoi le nucléaire le nucléaire
ça sert à dissuader avant tout et depuis
le début souvenez-vous le crel à la
crimée où des lacrymos et russe donc
faut pas y toucher il ya eu des attaques
en crimée est ce qu'il ya eu
d'utilisation du nucléaire non à chaque
fois ça a été du langage nucléaire
jamais de l'utilisation du clerc sera
donc ses doigts une guerre de position
aujourd'hui à laquelle ben et là les si
les ukrainiens réussi cette offensive
ils ont réussi à repousser les russes de
l'autre côté du nieppe s'ils le font
avant l'hiver ça sera déjà une belle
victoire après ça on verra pour la suite
ça sera plus compliqué ça va durer très
longtemps mais ça sera déjà une belle
victoire remportée par l'armée
ukrainienne qui en a besoin pour son
moral car énervé parce que c'est
effectivement compliqué de reprendre une
centrale nucléaire comme ça je peux pas
vous répondre je ne suis pas
spécialement
ce qui est compliqué c'est que les
russes reprennent en main l'exploitation
de la centrale ça il faut être fort mais
il faut les procédures sont en ukrainien
les matériels les équipes en ont été
améliorées depuis 10 30 ans en ukraine
donc ça c'est par horizon c a besoin des
ukrainiens ils ont demandé une
correction à court moyen terme pour
exploiter la centrale juste juste un
point je rappelle que coke la centrale a
été pris a pas eu de combats n'ont cure
ça a été des unités des unités russes
contre des civils qui ont utilisé des
lacrymogènes et qui ont utilisé le
subterfuge de mettre un incendie à
l'intérieur pour faire rentrer les
pompiers et fait rentrer les militaires
russes en même temps il n'y a pas eu de
combats donc la question comment on fait
pour reprendre une centrale nucléaire
avec des combats je n'ai pas la réponse
non plus mais c'est très dangereux à mon
avis je lance maison ça reste très
dangereux effectivement de reprendre
cette centrale ça reste très dangereux
et on va voir comment se débrouillent la
mission de la ja je pense qu'il faut
quand même garder leur d'optimisme parce
que les chefs d'état du monde entier
regarde cette mission et après tout est
là y va tous les pays sont membres de
l'aea et dans la mission parmi les
techniciens et il ya un chinois
il ya une française ce sont des
techniciens ils sont pas là pour pour
des motifs politiques mais enfin il est
probable que les gouvernements vont
réagir chaque jour à ce que dira le chef
de la mission de l'oea est ce qu'il
faudrait obtenir c'est en effet une
forme de de présence internationale
permanente sur cette centrale on
arrivera à croyez ça
intéresse ça dépend de l'intérêt de
poutine à ce moment là ça dépend aussi
de la situation
à carson bien entendu si poutine arrive
à résister à l'offensive ukrainienne il
peut perd peut-être se permettre une
certaine forme de couverture
internationale sur un port ide chat dans
le cas contraire certainement pas bien
entendu parce que l'opinion publique
comment expliquer ça cela à l'opinion
publique russe d'autant plus que
apparemment le ministère le midi de la
défense a un petit peu disparu du
paysage russe et le chef d'état-major
aussi donc ça se passera d'ailleurs pas
une série fort goût parce que on a bien
vu sur les images de monsieur choïgou
assis sur le bord de son fauteuil
rendant compte au président poutine
enfoncé confortablement dans son
fauteuil qu' il n'est plus très en cours
et il n'est plus très en cour il lui
rend compte en lisant un papier préparé
à l'avancé parce que le président
poutine n'est pas content du déroulement
de sédières aucun aucun aucun de ces
plans là n'a été réalisée aucune de ces
prévisions il a été réalisé ce qu'il
voulait c'était un changement de régime
dans le fond comme le faisait autrefois
les américains un changement de régime
et qu'il y aurait pu se produire en
trois jours pensait-il déclare mais ce
serait monté session s'est montrée à
kiev c'est exactement l'inversé qui
s'est produit et donc il ya quand même
des responsabilités en effet au niveau
du commandement est probablement dû du
ministre de la défense minable donc ce
sont les chefs des théâtres d'opération
qui semble-t-il rendre compte
directement à poutine qui est devenu
chef de guerre tetiana au hoggar kova
est-ce que vous pensez que les
ukrainiens souhaite comme le disait
justement claude blanchemaison qu'il ya
une mission internationale de un terme
au tour justement de cette centrale de
zaporijia
oui je pense que la majorité on pense
que il faut non seulement c'est que
cette mission se pérennise qu'elle soit
toujours voilà elle là bas mais aussi
que l'objectif très ambitieux on
comprend mais l'objectif de
démilitariser la zone des d'éloigner les
troupes russes que ça devienne une
réalité puisque on comprend très bien
que le risque est toujours là si les
combats sont justement autour et dans la
centrale donc bien sûr le contrôle
international et il permet la visibilité
aussi de ce qui se passe à la centrale
puisque les crèmes étant donné que le
territoire est occupé et ceci depuis
plusieurs mois on n'a pas d'accès en
fait à des informations nécessaires on
voit pas comment ça se passe après il ya
toujours la propagande russe qui dit
voilà je vous remarque que la formule
que les russes et les ukrainiens
s'accusent mutuellement que voilà comme
si comme si et l'ukraine pouvait qui
rayent sur sa propre centrale parce que
guy roux est ce que vous dites donc ça
on fait au je remarque que la propagande
de russes fonctions et donc je les
attire surtout l'attention sur le fait
que vit bien sûr il ya une certaine
rationalité il y avait un plan assez
rationnelle de la russie de rattacher
les centrales au système russe mais
visiblement d'après ce que disent
plusieurs experts ici en ukraine ça n'a
pas marché aujourd'hui deux réacteurs
sont reliés donc nous marche pour
l'ukraine c'est à dire que son plein au
rationnel que de voler entre voilà qu'on
prend au niveau laisse la centrale ça
n'a pas marché donc pourquoi ils la font
pourquoi ils le gardent justement
pourrait figurer à voir son chantage
donc on parle de terrorisme nucléaire et
rien d'autre en fait ils le gardent pour
justement mettre la pression monstre
marc sur le crâne mais aussi sur toute
la communauté internationale de 8,57
rebondir sur cette expression terrorisme
nucléaire effectivement les 200 parties
se renvoient la balle sur est ce qu on
sait qui finalement a bombardé cette
centrale on a des images très nettes
inde attaques par des drones d'ukraine
ukrainien sur le pourtour c'est pas je
pardonnez moi je viens d'un autre
plateau où on nous a montré clairement
ces images donc il y a contestation
possible maintenant c'est pas sur la
centrale c'est sur les pourtours
de deuxième point
moi je peux pardonnez-moi mais la
centrale sous le contrôle d spécialisée
est centrale les russes veulent la faire
fonctionner pour le sud de l'ukraine
alors qu'ils auront occupé alors qu'ils
n'y arrivent pas tout de suite peut-être
mais la connexion au réseau sud c'est
quelque chose qu'ils peuvent envisager
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont pris cette
centrale c'est pas pour faire du
terrorisme nucléaire c'est pour avoir un
instrument économique et ils ont besoin
de cet instrument économique c'est pour
ça que c'est si important pour eux et
c'est pour ça que c'est si important
pour l'ukraine qui en a besoin parce que
pour l'économie ukrainienne c'est
essentiel car nerveux c'est facile pour
les russes de raccorder une partie de
l'électricité de sept produits parfaits
centrale sur d'autres territoires comme
la crimée d'autant que la seule ligne
d'alimentation puissance de la centrale
c'est celle qui va vers le nord donc
aujourd'hui les deux autres lignes elles
sont défaillantes depuis depuis les
invasions l'invasion russe en guest
qu'ils essayent de faire exactement en
fait je ne sais pas ce qu'ils essayent
de faire moi je vois que là les lignes
de défense prévus pour assurer la sûreté
sont fragilisés aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'incident ni d'accidents à la centrale
les partis qui ont été touchées sont des
partis qui ne sont pas vitales pour la
centrale n'y a pas de risque direct de
rejet radioactif d'ailleurs c'est
surveiller quotidiennement par contre il
ya effectivement des risques
liés à ces à ces sources électriques
la réalimentation du sud me paraît
compliqué aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'état des lignes de haute tension donc
elle est très risquée cette eau de
relier justement cette centrale au sud
où donc à la crimée c'est très risqué de
le faire ou pas il faudrait que les
lignes soient disponibles aujourd'hui
elles elles ne sont pas donc ils ne
peuvent pas le faire les russes pour
l'instant intérieur terme non ils ne
peuvent pas le faire parce que les
ukrainiens disent que c'est ce qu'ils
font à écouter des informations que l'on
a sur les lignes d'export de
l'électricité les lignes du sud ne sont
plus disponibles le blanche maison
mais ça montre bien que ces opérations
étaient mal préparées du côté russe
parce que c'est tout à fait clair que
les russes voulait amener de l'eau d'une
épreuve en crimée pour avoir de l'eau
potable de l'eau douce est également de
l'électricité et que peut-être en effet
n'était-il pas tout à fait au courant de
l'état technique des lignes du sud et
que d'ailleurs ça expliquerait que après
avoir déconnecter le réseau ukrainien
pendant une journée ils les reconnecter
parce que finalement ils sont aperçus
que c'était pas possible de faire ce
qu'il voulait faire et ce serait encore
une fois
preuve de la du manque de préparation de
cette de cette opération militaire on a
constaté depuis le début depuis début
les colonnes de chars sur les routes
goudronnées où il suffisait que les gens
dans l'est dans les buissons
tirs sur le premier char et sur le
dernier char pour que la colonne soit
bloquée et détruire tranquillement tous
les autres chats dans le reste de la
journée d'un monde quand même un degré
de préparation assez surprenant assez
sidérant un problème de commandement un
problème d'entraînement un problème de
matériel qui est assez sidérant je pense
que poutine en effet a dû être très très
mécontent de voir cet état de choses est
que les sanctions ont été prises mais
des niveaux intermédiaires parce
qu'effectivement il faut pas que ça se
voie trop donc ça peut pas être au
sommet mais effectivement l'erreur
stratégique c'est que l'attak du 24
février devait se terminer le 27 ou le
28 par la chute du gouvernement et donc
une manoeuvre militaire pour s'emparer
de l'ensemble n'était j'allais dire
qu'une une promenade militaire
accueillis par des ukrainiens qui les
auraient accueillis ceux ci a échoué il
fallait monter donc une autre opération
et on a bien vu que dans ce changement
d'opération et russes ont pas été très
bon ils ont mis deux mois pour basculer
toutes les forces vers le donbass et
quand il avance vers le donbass ils
avancent très doucement il avance quand
même mais ils avancent très doucement la
seule réussite ça a été à partir d'un
crime et vers personnes par le sud elle
a été la seule russie va et craignait
d'aujourd'hui donc oui bien sûr d'autres
d'où l'importance pour les ukrainiens de
montrer que d'ailleurs le gouvernement
ukrainien été critiqué sur sa défense au
nord de la crimée on a dit vous n'aviez
pas préparez vous aviez préparé vers le
donbass mais pas vers la crimée et donc
vous êtes fait surprendre par
l'offensive russe par le sud est d'où
l'importance pour les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui de gros reconquérir cette
partie là tt now garko va comment voyez
vous un peu la suite de cette guerre au
delà justement du risque nucléaire
représentés par la centrale de zaporijia
vous pensez que cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne que les ukrainiens vont y
arriver au final en tout cas qui
militairement
écoutez il est très difficile de prévoir
des choses qu'un pialat vieira c'est
vrai que là on comprend on se rencontre
que la guerre ça serait ça sera pas
court parce qu'encore au mois de mai
genre et notamment au 10 juillet quand
l'offensive russe a carrément stoppé
parce qu'après les sites chance qui
avait pas de changement majeur n'est ce
pas de n'y avait pas de leurs qualités
qu'ils ont pris donc ça fait presque
deux mois que koné au point mort en
quelque sorte mais non moins optimiste
je vous lis pas ce qu'on comprend que la
tactique employée par les russes et les
elle consiste à faire le mettre le
maximum pour garder les troupes en vue
donc pour progresser très prudemment et
puis les armes mais on y arrive il
arrive vraiment une raison très moderne
mais en quantité qui n'est pas suffisant
il faut aussi dire que personne n'était
prêt à cette guerre ni le crains
d'ailleurs est donc le point évoqué sur
la faiblesse de l'ukraine au sud le
démontre prénommé aussi le fait que les
stocks erpion désarmement était vraiment
pas vivre mais vraiment et comporter des
désarmements quantité des dizaines tant
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui des
centaines pour faire face à la russie
donc ça prouve que tout le monde
civilisé
malheureusement on n'était pas prêt à
une guerre donc pape en tout cas une
guerre de gendre que la russie mène
aujourd'hui une guerre du 20e siècle 19e
siècle voire donc quand on est au 21ème
siècle donc c'est une guerre avec des
chars avec des des hélicoptères avec des
avions avec des tranchées avec gare tirs
--dont qu'ils utilisent les tactiques de
la terre raser la terre brûlée on voit
ce qui se passe à d'une basse et il
avance en détruisant carrément tout sur
leur champ c'est-à-dire que les maîtres
mots tout à plat il ya que des ruines
qui restent derrière donc c'est on parle
pas de l'occupation parce qu'on se pose
la question à quoi bon libéré en trio
mais ces territoires pour avoir des rues
non pas des moyens en fait d'eux les
envies cir pour les restaurer rogan et
margot paul qui tombait depuis plusieurs
mois déjà donc une idée reportage il n'y
a pas d'eau potable il n'y a pas
d'électricité il ya que des ruines donc
il ya des maladies qui se propage donc
tout ça on comprend que ces tactiques en
fait donc l'armée kriens et une affaire
pour plusieurs mois vraiment voir année
mais ce qui est important donc je
termine nation ce que aujourd'hui les
ukrainiens à la question qu'est ce qu'on
est prêt à faire une guerre longue et
répondre par la positive puisque on
comprend que si on n'avait pas poutine
maintenant donc on va avoir une autre
guerre encore plus grande plus long
c'est à dire pas de cessez le feu par
des négociations pas des concessions sur
les territoires on va pas s'arrêter
avant de libérer la crimée le sud des
lichens et l'audace club en faisant
france que dix a effectivement tetyana
hoggar koval c'est que les ukrainiens
veulent récupérer aussi la crimée ça
fait partie de nouveaux objectifs 2 et
là ce qui est ce qu'il peut y avoir un
basculement moment de cette raspoutine
ça monte vers le dégel est ce que cet
hiver les choses seront différentes
moi ma conviction c'est que
malheureusement le conflit va durer que
la guerre quand on y va durer encore au
moins 12 mois 1 an s'agit peut-être plus
peut-être us peut-être ce que vous venez
quand on voit les photos on voit les
buts de guerre de de la russie d'une
part de l'ukraine de l'autre c'est
rigoureusement incompatibles monsieur et
l'inscrit maintenant au début ils
disaient qu'ils étaient prêts à faire
quelques compromis maintenant il dit je
veux récupérer l'intégrité du territoire
de l'ukraine bien sûr c'est son objectif
de guerre et ça n'est probablement pas
possible sans une intervention des
américains sans une intervention de
l'otan or la dissuasion nucléaire cette
fois ci une dissuasion stratégique
nucléaire l'interdît l'empêchent par
conséquent la russie ne peut pas être
vaincu dans cette guerre et de la même
manière et bien de l'ukraine ne sera pas
vaincu parce que il est soutenu par les
pays occidentaux
par la fourniture d'armes sans personnel
combattants sur place sur le territoire
mais c'est les conditions on voit bien
on voit bien une ligne de front se
dessiner elle peut bouger un petit peu
personne peut d'ailleurs tombés en effet
mais fondamentalement on voit bien
malheureusement une ligne de partage qui
ne sera d'ailleurs reconnu par personne
sur le plan international vous êtes
d'accord oui alors le le premier point
personne n'était prêt à la guerre la
guerre en europe personne ne l'imaginé
et les russes n'ont pu il n'était pas
prêt à la guerre il était prêt à prendre
en trois jours mais pas faire la guerre
comme il ya font maintenant et donc ça
veut dire que ça va durer très longtemps
quand on parle en moi moi je compte en
années et ça va durer très longtemps
avec la limite bien sûr que nous allons
soutenir l'ukraine tout le monde le dit
soutenir l'ukraine longtemps sans
intervenir directement est ce qu'il peut
se passer quelque chose en russie dans
les années qui viennent
c'est ce que tout le monde espère mais
ça veut dire des sanctions qui frappent
la russie dans deux ans dans trois ans
pas aujourd'hui la vidéaste et sans dire
des changements majeurs voilà je
remercie beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dominent trinquant merci claude
blanchemaison merci à vous karine
herviou merci tetiana hoggar kova
d'avoir été avec nous en direct de kiev
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
et vous restez avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]